we have to hold him to these pledges and
our plan for doing that is to fight in
areas particularly areas where people
voted leave and now have a remainer Pro
second referendum MP to get voices into
Westminster to hold him to account it
but this is where this is a number of it
and this is still you are still a
problem you are still a thorn in the
side of the Conservative Party because
the seats that you're going to fight are
the seats that burst Johnson needs to
win for the Conservative Party if he's
got any hope for a majority these are
labour seats they are Tory targets can
you just be clear on this are you still
going to fill candidates absolutely in
all of these seats yes that's right we
are and you know it will be a full-on
attack on labor who have broken their
promises and their 2017 manifesto and
who for many people in these northern
constituencies it feels like a London
Labor Party now there'll be seats in
which there are closer challenges a
Labour and seats indeed in which we are
a closer challenger to Labour let's see
what happens this isn't the beginning of
a u-turn is that you're not going to do
another u-turn in a couple of days time
where you say now I'm going to stand
down we've made our minds update so that
we might we've made our minds we've made
our minds you're not this is it now this
is the final let it be clear we are
fighting 300 seats not 600 seats and we
will focus our activities our efforts
into those areas
I heard all of this back in 2015
every commentary 2015 and every
commentate yeah but who won the election
in 2015 and why why why because because
because because the offenders because
what we did split the vote in 2015 the
Labour vote and that was that was Watson
has to win these labour targets see he
has to win some of them absolutely I've
given him a chance to defend the ones
he's got already he doesn't need to win
many more to have a majority